I was just calling cuz I'm wondering do
you have like a like a flat back of your
head is that why you go to mullet cuz I
mean I cut my hair like every couple
months I said grow now and I notice I
kind of got a flat head are you hiding a
flat head behind that mullet I mean I
appreciate you get back to me about that
alright bye
okay well appreciate you checking in
about this uh you know about an adult
man's hair and there's nothing wrong
with that you know think about men's
hair over time cavemen had all hair they
used to [ __ ] tie their eyebrows into
their into their into their bangs isn't
it imagine how stupid that looked and a
lot of them did it you know they would
some people grow their beard out tie it
around their neck to keep their hair
back that was all so long so your beard
within you have it split their beard and
use it to tie their hair back Vikings
did that men would braid their hair
white men wore wigs and their hair white
wigs like hey dude could you be any more
[ __ ] white okay and they put powder
in them so that when they shook their
head a little bit of white smoke fell
out men have always made poor hair
choices Prince
kind of a cute guy honestly hair looked
like [ __ ] 100% dude Rosie O'Donnell
never you know not a decent haircut for
a young male who else bro okay then you
go into who else had hair Oh jheri curl
which I think should come back where's
the jheri curl at huh huh black friends
where is that jheri curl where is it
cuz I know it was hoppin when I was
young my vice-principal had it my
buddy's dad had it you know I'm sayin
you used to see that drip drip that drip
drip drip drip drip let the ladies know
you leakin with swag but no men are fray
are brave enough to bring it back where
is it
you know I sometimes I'm like what's up
with these styles y'all afraid y'all
afraid to drip out the back a little bit
y'all afraid to [ __ ] flood out that
hang time to put that floss floss cam
and let's see it so men have always made
poor haircut decisions is what I'm
saying but am i hiding a flat head I
don't think so I mean I feel like this
to be totally honest with you I feel
like I have a bigger nose so you know a
lot of the black kids when I was young
would say you have a in nose they used
to say and they would say the n-word at
me about it
and also I could smell you know I know I
could smell pretty good and so you know
you got to have that intake bruh you
know and I'm built like a [ __ ]
panther and I need more air to come in
because my brain isn't low function you
know when I was young they said
something's wrong with my brain probably
and I don't know who said it but they
wrote it on a napkin too and my mother
has it in my baby book even but what
else was I telling you about oh I'll
tell you this oh do we hear more your
call oh but I don't think I'm hiding
anything you know and I don't know if
this is necessarily a mullet it's kind
of just like a long hair you know it's
crazy it's like some people you know
it's just like a hockey haircut I guess
I mean it's just long hair have you ever
had it I'll tell you this but having
long hair it's changed my life because
what happened was I was looking at
pictures of myself and I like man I hate
I always hated having short hair and I
was always afraid to grow up my long
hair and I lived here in Hollywood and
like you got to look kind of like a you
know yo you're gonna be a leading man I
ain't a [ __ ] leading man boy you know
I'm saying I'm a sidekick daddy you know
so I'm looking like I'm gonna look and
so I grew my Mane out until if I die if
I die out there in the desert or in a
mountain or if I fall into a wishing
well
and I die even though I have so many
wishes and none of them get me out of
there I want them to look and see me and
say that man had a mane that was a man
or a very thin lesbian
that man or her dead but they had a
style they had some passion hanging off
the back of that neck I'd only be out
there this [ __ ] oh the Sun might get
me oh it's uh uh
anything can happen all the rains gonna
hit me some of the rains not gonna get
me when I got this style
what's that weather ooh maybe nothing
cuz I have a little bit of protection I
got a Maine boy and if you see me in the
desert or you see me outside sometimes
at night I'll turn around to be nine
raccoons behind me with their dicks out
cuz they [ __ ] can feel that I am a
man onward thank you guys for checking
out this clip and if you want to see
another clip then you can look at this
clip or this clip either one of these so
did you pick one or he's still just
watching me do this because this is
alarming